>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
HERE WITH REACTION TO ALL THIS
BREAKING NEWS TODAY.
HE'S THE HOST OF LEVIN TV RIGHT
HERE ON THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL,
NUMBER-ONE SHOW, SUNDAY NIGHTS,
10:00 EASTERN.
I CALL HIM THE GREAT ONE.
"LIFE, LIBERTY AND LEVIN" IS THE
NAME OF THE SHOW.
WE HAVE THE APPOINTMENT MUELLER
BY ROD ROSENSTEIN BECAUSE SIXS
IS RECUSED.
YOU HAVE BEEN SAYING IN THE LAST
24 HOURS ON YOUR RADIO SHOW, AND
YOU TOLD ME PRIVATELY, THAT THIS
VERY WELL VIOLATES OUR
CONSTITUTION AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY THE APPOINTMENT'S
CLAUSE.
I WANT YOU TO REALLY EXPLAIN
THIS TO OUR AUDIENCE TONIGHT.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE SEED WAS
PLANTED WHEN I HAT TIPPED THE
PROFESSOR, AN OLD FRIEND OF MINE
WHO WORKED FOR ATTORNEY GENERAL
MEESE.
THE APPOINTMENTS CLAUSE.
IT'S IN THE CONSTITUTION.
IT APPLIES TO PRINCIPAL OFFICERS
OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
THAT'S INTERIOR OFFICERS, YOU
KNOW, LIKE A CHIEF, AN
ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANT, THEN
PRINCIPAL OFFICERS.
EVERY SINGLE UNITED STATES
ATTORNEY IN THE UNITED STATES
HAS TO BE NOMINATED BY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE
BECAUSE OUR FOUNDERS MADE CLEAR
THAT THEY WANTED BOTH BRANCHES
OF GOVERNMENT INVOLVED IN
APPOINTMENTS OF THE SENIOR LEVEL
PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE ASSISTANT SCARIES IN
DEPARTMENTS AND CABINET
SECRETARIES AND U.S. ATTORNEYS.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
THE APPOINTMENT OF MUELLER IS
UTTERLY UNCONSTITUTION FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS.
ROD ROSENSTEIN GAVE HIM AN
AGENDA THAT IS SO BROAD, NOT A
SPECIFIC INDIVIDUAL, NOT A
SPECIFIC STATUTE, NOT EVEN A
SPECIFIC MATTER, AND NOT ONLY
WAS THE INITIAL APPOINTMENT
INCREDIBLY BROAD, HE KEEPS
EXPANDING IT.
SO THIS SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
DIFFERENT THAN PAST SPECIAL
COUNSELS.
HE'S MORE LIKE A ROVG U.S.
ATTORNEY.
ALSO, WE LEARNED SOMETHING TODAY
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE.
IT SAYS COURT FILINGS INDICATE
WHEN LAWYERS APPEARED IN COURT
EARLIER THIS YEAR, THEY DID SO
NOT ONLY AS REPRESENTATIVES OF
MUELLER'S OFFICE BUT THEY
RECEIVED AN APPOINTMENT, A
SPECIAL ASSISTANT UNITED STATES
ATTORNEY APPOINTMENT IN THE
EASTERN DISTRICT OF VIRGINIA.
THEY ARE, IN EFFECT, ASSISTANT
UNITED STATES ATTORNEYS.
ROBERT MUELLER WANTED TO EXPAND
THEIR POWER.
THEY REPORT TO HIM.
IF THEY'RE ASSISTANT UNITED
STATES ATTORNEYS OR SPECIAL
ASSISTANT UNITED STATES
ATTORNEYS THAT MAKES MUELLER,
WITHOUT QUESTION, THE EQUIVALENT
OF THE UNITED STATES ATTORNEY.
WHAT'S UNIQUE ABOUT HIM AND PAST
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL AND SPECIAL
COUNSEL IS THE MASSIVE BREADTH
OF HIS INVESTIGATION.
HE'S GOING TO INTO BANK FRAUD,
WIRE FRAUD, HE'S GOING INTO
RUSSIA, A NUMBER OF OTHER
COUNTRIES.
HE'S INTERVIEWED HUNDREDS OF
INDIVIDUALS, TENS OF THOUSANDS,
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOCUMENTS.
HE'S NOT AN INTERIOR EMPLOYEE,
LIKE AN STRAV ASSISTANT OR
ANYTHING OF THAT SORT.
HE'S A PRINCIPAL OFFICER.
UNDER THE APPOINTMENTS CLAUSE OF
THE UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION,
ARTICLE II, Mr. ROSENSTEIN
USURPED THE AUTHORITY OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO NOMINATE WHOMEVER HE WANTS AS
PROSECUTOR AND Mr. ROSENSTEIN
STATES SMATH WHICH HAS THE
CONTROL -- Mr. MUELLER IS
SERVING UNCONSTITUTIONALLY IN
VIOLATION OF THE APPOINTMENTS
CLAUSE OF THE CONSTITUTION
BECAUSE OF THE WAY ROSENSTEIN
APPOINTED HIM, BECAUSE OF
EXPANDING HIS AUTHORITY, BECAUSE
Mr. MUELLER HAS EXPANDED HIS OWN
AUTHORITY WITH THESE FOUR NOW
ASSISTANT UNITED STATES
ATTORNEYS AND EVERY DEFENDANT IN
THIS CASE, EVERY WITNESS IN THIS
CASE, EVERYBODY WHO RECEIVED A
SUBPOENA IN THIS CASE, WHATEVER
FEDERAL COURT IT IS, SHOULD
RAISE THE ISSUE OF THE
APPOINTMENTS CLAUSE OF THE
CONSTITUTION THAT Mr. MUELLER IS
CONDUCTING HIMSELF AND IS
APPOINTMENT IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
SEE, HERE'S THE DEAL.
THESE CAREER BUREAUCRAT
PROSECUTORS, THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE CONSTITUTION.
THEY UNDERSTAND PARTS OF IT,
LIKE DUE PROCESS AND PROXIMATE
CAUSE.
THEY NEVER READ THE APPOINTMENTS
CLAUS.
THEY NEVER READ THE SUPREME
COURT DECISIONS INVOLVED IN
THAT.
I HAVE.
PROFESSOR HAS.
I WANT YOUR AUDIENCE TO KNOW
THIS, TOO.
SO, Mr. MUELLER, UNLIKE ANY PAST
SPECIAL COUNSEL OR ANY PAST
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL, THE BREADTH
OF HIS INVESTIGATION IS SO
MASSIVE, IT'S SO BROAD BY THE
INITIAL APPOINTMENT, THE
SUBSEQUENT EXPANSION AND NOW
FOUR OF HIS OWN PEOPLE GETTING
DUAL APPOINTMENTS AS EFFECTIVELY
AN ASSISTANT UNITED STATES
ATTORNEYS, Mr. MUELLER, HIS
CONDUCT, HIS APPOINTMENT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, THAT'S WHY I
CALL YOU THE GREAT ONE.
WHAT YOU SAY I HOPE EVERY
ATTORNEY INVOLVED IN THIS CASE
HEARD YOU AND IF YOU'RE OUT
UP ON foxnews.com PLEASE TWEET
IT OUT, PLEASE USE SOCIAL MEDIA
AND MAKE SURE THIS GOES VIRAL.
>> ALL YOU ATTORNEYS OUT THERE,
GO FOR IT, BABY.
I KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
IT.
>> Sean: THAT'S WHY WE CALL YOU
THE GREAT ONE.